[Music]
hello everybody welcome to this insane
Indian gaming lecture where we are
supposed to check complicated in games
or very very interesting
my name is Pepe a grandmaster from Spain
and you have any questions during during
the lecture please don't hesitate to ask
and you know that a lot of people say
that the immortal polish game was played
between Glucksberg and Nidal Finbar
Sofia in 1935 but some of the people say
that there is even a better game and
while doing research for this lecture I
found a really interesting game between
two polish players and where the end
game is extremely interesting so this is
the game that I want to show you and it
was played in a postman one of my
favorite cities actually I studied in
Danskin that in the north of Poland for
a semester and then we used to go every
weekend to do postman for some fun and
it was played between tills Koski and
Antony Moshiach Chatzky I'm not so sure
if my polish pronunciation is the best
but alright and this game has a lot of
controversy that I will try to explain
in at the end of the lecture because two
years later there were two other players
in Spain that managed to get the same
position at the end of the game and a
lot of people say that they just
prepared that they just cheated so in
order to reach that extremely beautiful
endgame so one of the opponents could
finish in a really beautiful way the
game some other people say that this
game between the Polish players was not
played in 1931 but after the the Spanish
game so I actually have no clue and we
cannot be sure about that but we can be
sure about the beautifulness of the of
the game so let's go over so till Kowski
played f4
in this position in the move number one
let me see if yeah now the software is
working you know how this difference is
sort of how this opening is called some
of you to Spanish Italian the English no
it's called the birds the birds opening
okay and it's like a Dutch defense but
with reverse colors it's not the most
popular of course because you know you
are weakening already York in in the
first move right and okay so black
continued with d5 controlling the center
III c5 Nera tree and knight c6 what what
do you think about the center here which
is the most important important square e
v a5 d 4e 4 so everything is going to
happen about the e5 square so that's why
you normally want to go Bishop b5 to put
pressure on the knight on c6 so then you
gain more control or of the of the e5
square so that's why in the game Bishop
b5 was played we have to say that the
quality of this game is not very very
good at least in the opening and in the
middle game because we are talking about
the game from the 40s right so it's not
a game between Kramnik and Magnus
Carlsen but still the game is quite
interesting so Bishop g4 was played
pinning this night from f3 and now sure
Castle and in six you wanna develop
finally the Kings side the Bishop from
f8 and the night from g8 and then you
want to go ashore castle in the next
move so here
how would you develop the Queen side
here you have to develop these minor
pieces how would you do it Tracy
you have any suggestion
since c4 is actually a very interesting
move so just trying to explode the
center here so how do you develop this
c1 Bishop c4 is a very interesting move
but you can also go d3 or b3 actually
both of them are quite reasonable in the
game
they went for d3 now Bishop e7 was
played you know that you continue with
native six and here Knight c3 just
developing another minor piece so these
moves are kind of natural here in the
game black went for d4 so this is not
very recommended so you normally first
wanna finish development with Knight f6
then put your kin in a safe place and
then maybe strike in the center with d4
but here after d4 where would you go
with your Knight to e2 to a4 to e4 or 2
b1
you can also take the pawn but at the
end of the day you're gonna have to move
the piece right so you have to vote
between efore and b1 where would you go
before it's much more natural yeah the
pieces to the center so the knight on e4
is developed in the game they went to be
one this is of course not a very good
move because you know you never want to
go back here there's no reason then I
Tony four is putting pressure on c5
controlling important squares such as t6
and f6
so night b1 not the best move and Knight
of six was played here now white
continued with E for so that's actually
a natural move I would have preferred to
take first on c6 because now after afore
you get black the opportunity to
reinforce this c6 Knight let's say by
Queen b6 or Queen c7 and now you want to
take this knight then blacks able to
recapture with the Queen so and his pawn
structure on the Queen side is not doing
so that's why I have two e4 black played
short Castle here again I prefer Queen
c7 to reinforce this knight on c6 but
they went sure Castle allowing Bishop
takes c6 now B takes c6 what color would
you take here you have to play this game
white or black
and why so one of the most difficult
things in chefs it is just to evaluate a
position who's better here
why who has the advantage even a lot of
grandmasters failed in this yeah in not
so much complicated positions so who has
the better structure white yeah
so with we don't have double points so
white has a really nice square for this
night on b1 on c4 right and then you
could say that black has to be super
that's a fact and this is always
something important but actually after a
tree black is going to have to give up
the bishop / because you go to h5 then
g4 + f5 wins apiece right so that's why
black has the bishop pair but just for
some minutes so I would take white with
no doubt in this position this Knight
and c4 is doing a fantastic job and then
I also have Sun attacking chances on the
key inside in the game white when c3 I
don't like this move at all because I
would have preferred to go 93 or 92 now
in order to go 94 but c3 has a small
problem let's see you if you guys can
find the best move here for black it's a
really tough move and basically the idea
is to get rid of your ugly pawn
structure c4 great c4 the point is that
this pawn on e4 is hanging so after C
takes t4 you're gonna always take on f3
and then take on d4 followed by Queen
takes d3 and if you take this pawn here
then I can imagine you can take this
pawn here we need 4 or maybe you can
even take on c3 but c4 was a really good
move
after c3 black tokens c3 now Knight
takes c3 Bishop f3 rook takes f3 and
Knight to g4 that's a move that is
correct
something actually what is black
straightening here in this position I
mean if I go for example stupid move
like a tree or Bishop d2 so black to
move here after Bishop d2 what do you
play black moves and wins material Queen
d4 exactly what happens if the King goes
to f1 sorry yeah native to fork winning
material if you go to h1 now I have to
check you are forced to take on f2 and
then you want an exchange right so
that's why after 94 white plays a
prophylactic move King h1 so now there
is no check on d4 but anyway black goes
Queen d4 here threatening Queen f2 and
now what would you play here with the
white pieces I mean there are many many
ways to stop knight of - I see like one
two three four five six six ways
Quincy one is the move that they tried
in the game I don't like this move
because okay after Quinn take c1 Kim
take c1 I think the end game is more or
less equal but for example if you go
something like Queen e1 or Queen e2
let's say Queen e1 now your next move is
going to be a tree and this Knight has
to waste another tempo because it has no
active squares to jump and then you're
going to develop this Bishop with
another temple so basically you're
winning saw so many Champy and white is
actually much better you have also some
attacking ideas again against black skin
but 21 of course is not it's not a bad
move to part with the threat and after
Queen take c1 Kintex e1 now black has
this terrible Bishop and I'm Tony bossy
a shot ski tried to activate activate it
sorry by playing Bishop d8 his idea was
to go Bishop b6 here and in this
position again it was interesting and it
at this point to go c4 and then tried to
look for some kind of content play after
detects e4 this Bishop c5 check again
it's not easy to go to f1 because it's
not H - it's not easy to go to h1
because there are some checks on f2
which are really nasty here so after kim
takes it one bishop d8 just going for
some trick cheap trick I will say Bishop
d8 now white when Bishop e3 I move that
I don't like
of course because you could go for
example a three kick this Knight back
and then you can develop the bishop boom
put pressure on c5 and then sooner or
later this point is going to fall you
can go on a leaf or you can go rook c1
and there's going to be so much pressure
and c5 that this point is going to fall
but after Bishop d8 white when Bishop e3
we're saying that this game is not the
best game in the world but the end game
you're gonna see so 90 X III rook takes
c3 and now Bishop be
six what do you think black is trying to
to do in the next move if we don't react
correctly it looks quite easy right
black straight so what what's black
straight here
c4 right so this Bishop is looking our
king with x-rays and also the route that
could be an ass tipping here on this
diagonal so that's why in the game white
went rook d1 here I will I would have
preferred to go something like King F 1
then C 4 exist remove my route but then
in the game they went for root T 1 and
now black player went for 8 6 a move
that is actually not so good because you
don't nip still some pressure to your
king
the game is focused on the center and
now it was important to go for c4 in
this in this moment so you are forced to
play something with white here what do
we have to play d4 only move otherwise
we're gonna lose some material right so
d4 only move and now what would you play
here with black now it's an important
moment it's really an important moment
so my question is would you go f6 or c5
what we want to do is we want to open
this dialog for sure yeah so this Bishop
gets active and then we can pose some
problems to two white here but how do we
do it how do we start with c5 or f6
what's the idea behind f6
and is that idea is that idea good or I
mean let's let's put it like this what
do you play here with the white pieces
after c5 there's only one good move
Knight b5 to protect d4 92 you said
something else d5 is the best move by
far because you close this diagonal you
don't want this bishop to get active
right and then we saw that there is a
lot of trouble going on in this day Iona
so you don't want to open it if you play
something like Knight b5 you're gonna
lose almost immediately after a 6
because now you are forced to go back
and then C takes d4 with a fork here to
the rook on the night then there's also
this cover trick here going on basically
you blundered everything in this
position so that's why after sorry C for
D for f6 was very very interesting
because now you want to go a 5 and then
if you manage to go a 5 then the center
is gonna explode here for white and then
they're gonna be so much trouble going
on in this diagonal so probably the only
move is a 5 and then there's a lot of
tension with this rook f d8 for example
and it's not easy to protect the d4 poem
how would you try to protect the default
for now there are two ways ruk e 2 or 92
rookie for sorry or 92 92 why why not
rookie for f5 yeah rookie for you play
f5 them deviation this rook has to go
back and then you take this free point
okay so after
the ones in the game Seaforth was really
really interesting followed by f6
but then they decided to go for h6 all
right and now II 5 was played by till
Kowski again not the best move
what would you try here with the white
pieces we said that we are in trouble in
this diagonal so what do we do if I was
playing there I will just try to remove
pieces yeah I'm the kid
for example yet the rook and the King
for example root 3 or keen f1 but we
don't want to be in this diagonal not
the c4 we can decide if we want to play
d4 we can even now remove the rook and
bring it back to the to e1 or f3
whatever yeah but they went for a 5 now
another mistake by our friend Anthony
Bossier Kowski so hard polish to to
learn I was there for 6 months I just
learned like two words I think so good
morning and cheers yeah
nostrovia and how was good morning I
raised Jindo bridge in Dover all right
so what do we play now with the black
pieces they gave us another chance so
see for yeah we have to open this
they're gonna for this bishop and then
the only move is d4 and now what will
you play c5 or route d8 c5 half has a
problem same problem as before they
closed that I run out with d5 so
therefore route d8 is better and now if
we go 92 are we now ready to strike in
the center with c5 or not Tracy I would
ready to rhumble here with c5 yeah but
now there is a difference because now we
are protecting the D Phi square with two
pieces so now we can just take this
phone for free and this is just a pawn
for free so black could be winning here
so it was the time again to go for c4
but in the game they went for f6 okay
another interesting but bad move I would
say so it takes f6 look takes f6 and not
rook f3 finally black white player sorry
moved away from this diagonal and now
they went for c4 not the best moment but
still ok they managed to activate this
b6 bishop again now it was just much
better to go king of 1 so no pieces in
this iron gonna but then they decided to
glow to close with d4 and now again
rook d8 was a better move because after
c5 now you can imagine finally what
happened in the game d5 exactly d5 was
played it takes d5 rook takes d5 King
8/7 was played and now rook t7 it's
always very important to bring this rook
to the seventh rank I mean rooks in
general in end games should come to the
seventh rank they are extremely active
over
so in the game black decided to go for
this trade of Brooks who looks like
natural to me because this this rook on
a8 was extremely passive and then this
rook was very very active so that's why
I cooked the a this an interesting move
and why I decided to keep this rook on
the seventh rank Rob g6 was played
trying to go for route d2 and put
pressure here on g2 but the thing is
actually there's not so much pressure
going on you can play almost anything
here but not the move that they went in
there in the game they went for drug g3
which not which sorry was not very good
you could play g3 for example because
now after rook d2 there is a good move
for white here whoa sorry yeah sorry
so why to move counterplay we have a
majority on the keen side can we use it
with the temple
so if we have to use this majority here
on the kingside what poem moved you move
f5 right just now you win a temple here
and then you are threatening also f6 in
the next move let's say it black goes to
c6 then f6 just wins again because you
can take here because of the rook f6
there is a pin and then you cannot
recapture and f6 and you go rook f6 now
we can bring another guy to the action
exactly 94 very good move Tracy because
now we are pushing away this rook thrown
F from f6 and then we are going F 6
winning the game all right
as we said in the game they went for
rook G 3 rook takes c3 h takes G 3 rook
d2 and now white went and protect the b2
pawn and this is actually one of the key
moments in the game I couldn't believe
what happened in this end game when I
when I saw the moves the line that comes
now it's just so amazing so do you see
any ideas I'll give you like one minute
to think also the guys in YouTube you
can think too about this position I'll
actually open the chat so to see if you
guys have an idea
so I see Carlos Costa under UV a lot of
people there so guys also in the YouTube
channel you have to see any ideas after
night a for looks like white managed to
defend everything now white could also
scape with his cane via h2o also maybe
what is threaten to take on b6 at some
point and then b2 is Sims protected okay
what do you see here c3 is interested of
course but the problem with c3 ok there
is no real problem but I think black can
just take with the pawn and then after
root K to Knight b6 and you got nothing
yeah because up to 8 XV 6 took takes 3 6
and then this is probably going to be a
draw but nothing special for white it
looks like a stupid move what they
played in the game but it's actually a
winning move sacrifice the rook on b2
but of course why and then do we see the
whole line because we had to calculate
the whole line here some somebody said
rugby to Marwan and harm on rugby too
but then we have to see what happens
after night XV - so let's try to
calculate without moving the pieces ok
this is the way to improving chest
ninety-two yeah and for example what
happens if I go 93 okay let's see what
you're saying
takes takes c3 93 poncey two and then
for example I'll just go 91 and it looks
like I just woke up happy with my life
I'm gonna come here now to take your
policy - so route B 2 is correct but now
after C 393 it's actually a bad move but
for a reason and it's the reason it's
not C to always the same theme in this
in this game yeah after 93 somebody saw
it already in the YouTube channel Sunil
or coup D is the same idea all the game
with the black pieces c4 Tracy that's it
c4 check and now if you go with a cane
let's say to f1 now you're going to take
this knife here and then these two
passports joined by this Bishop are
going to win the game
so c3 sorry a c4 check and if rook takes
me six what do you play
sorry captured III that's the best move
I mean if you capture on v6 you lost
again because now night before you block
c2 you bring the kin you capture all
these guys here and then black has to
resign so you have to take this night on
d3 and there is no way of stopping these
two points maybe you can try for example
if you go route b3 I'll go see - you
can't take this poem because there is c1
and then let's say it rook b3 c2 or d2
whatever works
rook c3 and now d2 rook takes and d1 and
black boots again same story happens
after keen f2 well not the same story
now you gotta be careful what do you
play now d2 or seat you it's really
important now sorry and d2 why why it's
not working d2
exactly so d2 loses actually because now
after kini - you cannot push your pawns
after c2 it just take this pawn and keep
an eye on this c1 squared so you gotta
go C to here now the only move for wipe
to stop that pony's rook c6 and now d2
right so now you have to capture here
and then d1 just wins the game
so we saw that after rook be to 90 HP to
c3 Knight d3 is not working so night c4
is not working because now c2 and then
there is no way of stopping this guy
here again so white has to take on b6
and what do we play now with the white
with the black pieces see two losses why
it comes off nag D three stops upon
exactly c4 here amazing move what do we
do now with the white pieces we cannot
take on c4 cus after C two blacks
winning and then our threat is quite
simple so basically if you do nothing
I will go C to in the next move and then
c1 unstoppable so can you find a way for
y2 to protect is to defend this I see
some so what do you guys here what's
your best right here to to stop those
pawns so we have to take in mind that
black has already sacrificed our rook
and a piece but we have these little
twins
Carlito's twins on the C file and how do
we stop them guys in the YouTube channel
you have any ideas how to stop these C
pawns okay I'm going to suggest you
something
how about rook c6 what do you play now
with the black pieces rook cc's is
loosing immediately but then you have to
find a way
sorry yeah see takes me to then there's
no way of stopping b1 right but now I'm
gonna give you a tricky move now for
white route before and then imagine you
have ten seconds in the clock and then
you have to make a move with the black
pieces a5 do you see any other move I
mean sorry
just wait you said so for example with
Kim G six or something I mean if you
wait now my thread of course is to take
this pawn on c4 now you take this night
on b2 this route before and then white
wins the game so you said a5 something
else
a five is actually a brilliant move boom
sorry not Kinji six but instead a five
because now if white takes on c4 then
seat xv2 and then you cannot go back to
be four because now these square is
covered by the a five-point right so fi
is a brilliant move that wins the game
but still we have to calculate one more
line so basically we are threatening
against CTools
if 90 XC four days see - Luke takes e4
desi takes me - I mean I don't also
attacking the rook so if you play keen
f2 then I'll just collect your look and
then I'll promote a quid so what's your
best right here for white I see a
language is not so clear to me anymore
so we have to try to defend this
position with the white pieces
Luque for the problem is seat actually -
so guys in youtube do you see a defense
here or na root beat free look be free
just loses again because seat xb3
bouquet for losses would be 3 losses
Knight d4 Knight takes e4 you mean this
one
924 it has the following problem it
takes before and now c2 and c1 is
impossible to stop so that's also a
problem our two heavy pieces are hanging
- so somebody saw it in the YouTube
channel sorry
he says Knight takes e4 Knight takes e4
because now he wants to take this pawn
on e5 sorry he wants to take this pawn
on e5 and after c1 he wants to hide this
skin on h2 and then we have one rook one
night and two points for the Queen which
is like 10 points versus 9 points but
there is a line which is very good for
black and then you win some material
let's see if you find it from this
position so c2
now it's why to play you have to compute
the following line 9 5 c1 queen teenage
- and then there is a move that wins the
game on the spot
Quincy fire on how about rookie four
over there
and how about
Kingi one you are almost there
very good okay it was that there is an
easier way so Knight takes a 5c one king
egg - and now you could give the cheque
straight away
no sorry Quincy five now root K 4 and
then you find a really nice way
ruk age 5 only move Kingi one Queen to
d1 and then check the king has to go
again to h2o f2 and then this rock falls
is Queen Bee five winning
how
so I mean the only move here for why
this rocketry so now black wins how keep
attacking pieces exactly Quinn before
that's it there's no way to protect both
pieces now you can remove this rook and
then this night is gonna fall I'm black
Black's winning okay so this was the
game now I have two more or at least one
more endgame this time is gonna be a
composition so we're not we're not gonna
check the whole game but this is a
really nice game because the endgame you
see this sacrifice is just unbelievable
I couldn't believe like when I saw this
position rook takes me to wins come on
but actually it wins remember the
sequence C 3 C 4 and a 5 so really
really beautiful
ok so I'm gonna show you now let me see
this is yeah this is the game this is
actually a composition from a Georgian
compulsion which is called Jorgen it's a
and I love solving artistic end games
because you know it's normally they are
not there are no positions we don't find
their positions that correspond to real
chess games from tournaments but it
helps a lot to improve our creativity
because the solutions are extremely
difficult in this position it's white to
move and it looks like we're gonna lose
almost immediately because f1 queen is
coming
so what do we do we have to find
desperate measures here
do you see any ideas I mean we're in a
desperate situation we have to find some
checkmate net or something like that
like so the first move is small as clear
right
a5 a5 and then only move king a6 and
suddenly we realize that if we manage
somehow to give a check to that Kim will
be made so so what ideas in there in a
perfect future come to your mind let's
say like you have three Tempe yeah you
can play three times so what how do you
checkmate this game and then B 4 and
then B 5 imagine that you have another
perfect dream and then you have another
three moves to play and there's some
actually there's another way to
checkmate that Kim you have three moves
and giving you three moves this maneuver
is not the only one to checkmate that
Kim one two three
yes exactly
somebody saw it in the YouTube channel
very good my friends who needle so you
guys so I mean if we are not going to
checkmate this guy with this one then we
have to use another piece the only
remaining piece that can give a check at
this guy so how do we bring the bishop
to the action three months
okay here is even easier yes sir with
two moves then we we check mate this
game yeah Bishop c2 am Bishop d3 but
there's another route
Tracy you saw it with this Bishop sorry
and then and then okay so this is going
to be very important when solving this
exercise this exercise is actually very
very difficult okay just try it
so because okay if we play King a for
now F 1 B for we're not on time to play
b4 y Queen captures the bishop and then
the skin will escape
so actually King a4 is not the solution
and if kin a4 is not the solution then
we have only two moves III and E for
efore okay let's see what happens
efore f1 and now what do you want to
play this should be sorry just one yeah
but I mean the module suggesting is
quite nice because you are threatening
checkmate in one move on c8 right so the
only move here for black is Queen f8
right and now let's say I want to go
King a for what would you play now with
the black pieces before it's actually a
bad move that loses but it's not that
easy to see why our idea is quite simple
now we want to go b4 and b5 Queen b8 I
think it's losing a sh Y because I go
before you want to go Queen b5 I guess
and then after King b3 you have no moves
the only move you can do is queen b 8
and then i can lose as many tempo as
sorry as many tempi as i want i could
play for example Bishop f5 then you have
to go Queen B 5 right because you have
no other moves you well couldn't be
files actually checkmate so you will
have to go well I'm not so sure about
this
let me think this is a draw because I
can go King a4 and then you have to go
back to be 5 because if you move the
Queen now away then there is b5
checkmate right so Queen B ADIS at the
best for progressive draw but this a
move here that wins a game after after
after King a4 for black
find another nice diagonal yeah somebody
saw it here but your wotty
so instead of b8 where do you want to go
Queen h8 that's a good move and now you
are after before of course you got Queen
a1 but I'm gonna make a tricky try a 5
what do you play now you want to take
this point with a quip because there is
checkmate on c8 right so you can take
this pawn with the Queen but now you can
actually go to b8 there is a big
difference now because the d5 pawn is
not protected so again if we try to do
the same thing as before now Queen b5
Kim b3 and remember the previous
position the pawn was on e4 so now we
can just simply take this pawn to d5 and
black wins so that's why there are so
many subtleties right in chess is so
difficult so if for losses because of
this maneuver Queen f8 Queen h8 we force
a 5 and now we go back to be 8 so if 4
is not working so what do we play and
why
III but let's try to understand the
whole the whole line so III F one Bishop
g4 Queen f8
somebody says III looks better to
protect efore sorry d4 sorry Kimmie for
so III have one can a for over there no
Bishop g4 o so III f1 Bishop g4 Queen f8
King a for Queen b8
okay let's move the pieces a little bit
so III so it will be easier to calculate
the one Bishop g4 stressing checkmate on
c8 Queen f8 and now it's one of the key
moments
Bishop e6 somebody saying Bishop e6
doesn't help much because now I want to
go queen bee a check came a for queen b5
King a3 and queen a5 and white blue seas
so we kind of waste a lot of time here
after queen afraid we have to be fast
I mean blacks ratings will go Queen B a
time Queen B 5
so any ideas okay I'll give you the next
move is King a for what do you think
black has to play here now actually
there are two alternatives to
interesting alternatives I mean we saw
the idea before right with the black
pieces so what will you play
Queenie where Queen be a this a move or
queen h8 borer
both are reasonable and I think the game
is a draw with both of them let's say
Queen h8 now we didn't see this idea
before in this position so now you have
to think and try to figure it out I mean
if we do nothing special black is gonna
have Queen a 1 and then we just lose
let's say we play before Queen a 1 check
King B 3 and Kim B 5 and then it's time
to resign because now later is coming
Queen B 1 followed by Queen before so
it's not that difficult because it's
kind of its kind of forced nobody in the
YouTube channel model Philippe Sunil
Bishop f5 again it should be 5 doesn't
work too slow too weak too slow Queen a
1 and a 5 point false this sorry
Bishop f8 is illegal move right CA
actually this is a brilliant move Bishop
CA but then you're gonna tell me why
after taking here I push the pawn queen
b8
and you think this is over but it's not
over is this over or is this drawer oh
you almost did it because now queen bee
five and then I collect this guy here on
d5 almost exactly p4 here and incredibly
this position is is a draw because now
there's only one possible move for black
okay you can play eight five and I can
play eight four but then there's only
one move for black here not too loose
immediately which is Queen b5 check
right you move the Queen to any other
square b5 is checkmate Queen B five and
now Kim b3 the key is that the d5 point
is protected so there's only one good
move for black here which is which is
quincy for all right
Quimby aid exactly keeping the Queen in
the board now King a four and then there
is a triple repetition
would you take here on a five is this
waiting for black is this winning for
white
I mean what happens here after Kim a5
who wins black white to move e5 great
how about if I take how about if I go
Kim b6 deserve and right perfect
okay so this is the key so that's why in
this position black can take on a fight
it has to go to b8 and after King a for
the position is a drop you see why these
exercises are so interesting because you
know this is almost never gonna happen
in a real chess game in a tournament but
it gives you a way to improve your
creativity for another kind of positions
in a chess in a chess game right okay so
we saw this polish immortal endgame with
sacrificing the rukon b2 and then
pushing c3 c4 and then this gained sort
of this composition from jørgen eater so
this will conclude the lecture for today
so thank you for coming
[Music]
you
you